[Music]
my future sister-in-law feels rejected
after we asked her not to bring their
dog to our one-year-old's birthday party
it sounds simple but unfortunately it's
kind of blown up in our face no it's not
simple at all because you're dealing
with madness
we are live
right now but you're hearing this like a
month from now so
i'm live you're not and i'm so glad that
we've connected some way across the
internet and uh across the youtubes and
the podcasts and the
evidently the tick tocks now all of them
all of them are so glad that you're with
us on the world's greatest parenting
relationship mental health marriage show
ever
dr john dolone's show i'm so glad that
you're with us if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at one eight four
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one it's one eight four four six nine
three three two nine
one and you can go to john delaney.com
ask we've got a fun show today um let me
know a couple of these calls and i'm
looking forward to it and
this is our second our second go because
the first time we started the show
ben on the board did not hit the record
button
but now we're recording
i appreciate you uh mentioning that
one of the things i love to do is is to
make myself feel better by pointing out
other people's flaws
it's just an operating strategy for me
it seemed to work just fantastic so far
oh man all right let's go to emily in
boise what's up emily
hi how are you i'm so good how about you
i'm doing pretty good excellent what's
up
all right so i guess a little back story
um i found out i was pregnant last year
at the end of july
and it was almost like the day i found i
was pregnant a light switch went off in
my brain and i became
like so scared of everything um
i think coming out of the pandemic
they're like don't trust any don't touch
anything don't do anything you're gonna
get sick and then pregnancy they're like
don't eat anything don't do anything
because not only will you get sick your
baby will get sick right
um so then
uh
i had really intense like ocd symptoms
kind of develop stronger and stronger
stronger throughout my pregnancy
and then i gave birth and everything was
okay for a little bit
and like i'm not as scared about like
bacterias and getting sick but i still
have like ocd
tendencies
so scared he's gonna get like lead
poisoning or
anything like that so anyway so i have
like these compulsions and behaviors
that i do to like prevent it
and i try to challenge them and remind
myself like
your logical brain know that
your baby likely won't get lead
poisoning
but if i don't wash my hands before i
feed him or if i don't do this or this
then
he will
so my question is how do i determine the
difference between like ocd thoughts
and anxiety versus like my actual like
mother's intuition
that's a good question
um can i ask you a few questions back
first
yeah okay
um
rarely and i mean super rare
is
like you talked about the light switch
does it does that happen outside of any
sort of historical context
so
when was the first time you
experienced anxiety or intense anxiety
or some sort of repetitive ocd-ish
symptoms
and i'm talking about like as a kid as a
14 year old has this been your whole
life
it's my whole life okay yeah i have
memories of even as like little little
kid
being scared
okay
where did those come from
where did what come from where did the
idea that
i can i can make a path of safety for
myself moving through the world by
controlling everything
i have to control everything so that i
can be okay
when did that story pop into your head
or who gave you that story
um
i don't know
i know so another little history thing
is i
uh had an eating disorder for a long
time and was in and out of treatment and
so i don't i don't struggle with that at
all anymore like it's almost like a
complete past self
but when i've talked about it with the
new ocd with like my family they're like
it's almost like you traded one for the
other
one form of control i would say the same
thing it's it's still the underlying
the underlying i don't use the word
pathology because i don't know you in
that context but the underlying
challenge is
i can can i can white knuckle i can grab
the steering wheel so tight that it can
never turn no matter matter the terrain
i'm driving over and we all know that's
not true or real so
most of us let go some of us
grab one even tighter right and we end
up with elbow issues and shoulder issues
and then we go to the doctor and say hey
my shoulder hurts and they give us some
sort of
uh
injection some cortisone
or they give us shoulder surgery and
really the problem is we're hanging onto
that wheel too tight right so back and
all the way out at some point either
that was the way you stayed safe as a
kid
because you grew up in a house of chaos
um or you had people that were right
next to you but they were involved in
other they were busy doing other things
and so you were trying to figure out how
i can like what was wrong with you and
you took control of that relationship
that shouldn't have been yours took
control of or you're an abusive
situation as a kid we could unwind it
for a long way even something is simple
so my dad um one of the things he used
to tell me
was hey every decision every choice you
make in life
you're throwing a giant rock into a lake
and you never know where the where the
rings of that lake of that rock hitting
the water where they're going to wash up
on
on shore even if it's across the lake
and you're responsible for where those
rings wind up so be careful about every
rock you throw and that was great wisdom
and i did not know how to compute that
so i got paralyzed by every decision
because i would be like well i got to
play 70 different scenarios out here
right and i'd end up doing nothing and
so that's one of those even even my dad
with great intention
right he was giving me a gift also
it wasn't a benign gift right so
let's fast forward all the way till now
okay intuition
um is most often a set of
is our body remembering something
okay
so
either your body's remembering that you
were out of control once or was
remembering a time that you read or saw
something so i don't want you to
overthink intuition does that make sense
i don't want you to romanticize
intuition
yeah i think the fear is like
what like
hypothetically and i logically know he
likely won't get lead poisoning but he
does get lead poisoning and it's traced
back to something that i did and then
it's like i should have known better i
thought about it and i chose not to
because i was challenging an ocd thought
but actually that thought was
not ocd it was real
i
um
there's not a difference
take diagnostics off the table they're
really confusing
they're mudding up your next step
okay you're i wouldn't think like is
this an anxious thought or is this an
ocd thought or is this a real thought i
wouldn't think like that at all your
thoughts are your thoughts or your
thoughts
okay and so stop trying to pull them
apart and and splice them and dice them
just simply sit for a moment and say
if i don't wash my hands
is my kid gonna get lead poisoning no
and your body will feel it and then you
can say hey thank you for taking care of
me
thank you for sounding all the alarms
i'm a good mom and i got this
and what you're doing is you are
letting go of the wheel instead of
tightening your grip on it
it doesn't letting go doesn't mean you
make bad choices or ding-dong choices or
you go rub your hands and like you know
cow manure and then go feed like that's
not what you're doing here but you're
also recognizing
um
we might get hit by a meteorite
and i'm not gonna spend my days
wondering what happens after a meteor
right i'll just deal with that when when
it happens you know what i'm saying
right definitely so the chance of you
know this statistically the chance of
your kid getting lead poisoning is very
very very low
unless he's eating paint off of an old
un you know
uh swing set somewhere we live in new
construction
right right so we know
that those alarms are not coming from
that fact
right the alarm is probably ringing off
the hook for one of two reasons
number one
you're a mom who just recognized for the
first time i
made peace with an eating disorder i
made peace with my body i've made peace
with my marriage i've made peace with
relationships
oh and then a huge variable just got
dropped into my world that i simply
can't control and i've heard it said i'm
watching my heart beat outside of my
body in this little boy
and i can't control any of the things
that happen moving forward
somebody's gonna break his heart
somebody's gonna be mean to him
he's gonna get in a car and drive across
the country one day all by himself he's
gonna get fired one day those things are
gonna happen someone he loves is gonna
get sick
those things are gonna happen and i
can't control any of it
and one of two things we can move
forward is we can double down and say
i'm gonna control it our body's gonna
scream at us control control
or i can make peace with i'm gonna do
the best i can with what i got
and i'm gonna make peace in that gap and
that's true healing does that make sense
so that's that's number one here's
another number two that could be the
case
it's not uncommon that somebody who had
childhood traumas when they have a kid
their body remembers that
and like so if let's say somebody was
sexually abused when they're seven it's
very common that somebody starts getting
really anxious at six when their kids
are six and a half
super anxious right and get really hyper
vigilant and they don't know that they
feel like they're going crazy and it's
simply their body remembering hey this
isn't safe
and so it that could be the case too for
you
yeah i think it's more the first one
because i have i'm
my son's the 25th grandchild on my
parents side and so
i was like i
i know what love is like i know what
love is like for because i have all
these nieces and nephews and um
i had no idea
uh yes it was
so soul-altering all right so i'm gonna
give you the demon of anxiety you ready
and i don't mean that like in some weird
i don't know like horned pitchfork kind
of way but i mean this this is why
anxiety is the worst
the more you
give into it
the stronger it reinforces itself
because your brain says
hey if
we need to wash our hands again and that
will make us feel a little bit safer for
half of a second right so i wash my
hands again and our body goes got that
little bit of
it feels good
and then the next time it's let's wash
them three times let's wash them four
times
and if you don't wash them four times
it's like
right so it just keeps moving itself the
only way through it is to turn and face
it and walk directly in the middle of it
right sometimes i do this thing where
i'm like i'm just gonna pretend like i
don't have ocd no more don't do that
don't do that like in the morning
don't do that walk right in the middle
of it know that know that i struggle
with anxiety
and by the way anxiety ocd i'm
i think they're exactly i think they're
on the same
i think they're two sides of the same
coin
right i actually have started thinking
i'm one i've always understood ocd to be
a derivative of anxiety i'm wondering if
it works the other way right now
here's the deal it doesn't matter it
it's literally academic gymnastics for
me at this point but i'm wondering if
um the the the neural loops that ocd
sits on is what spins out anxiety at the
end of the day who cares
when you start to need to wash your
hands
for the third time or the second time
stop
and intentionally look at your hands and
say they're clean
and i'm gonna lean into that discomfort
and then i'm gonna write it down
did not wash my hands again i feel
uncomfortable and i'm intentionally
feeling this discomfort and i'm gonna go
about it
i'm gonna go six minutes without washing
my hands again
right i'm gonna i'm gonna do these
things and lean into it here's the one
thing i'm
uh i wanna caution you against okay
your child will pick up on the titan
muscles
in the accelerated heartbeat and the
angst and now i'm making you angsty
about being angsty right i don't know
i'm gonna make it worse
um
no that those thoughts of
you're not planting anything
just watering them well right just
fertilizing the crap out of them um
i want you to aim towards
less towards getting every germ out of
your kid's life
and i want you to aim more towards
being as peaceful as possible
okay and that means i'm gonna head
directly into it the gold standard for
these type of things the nerd words is
exposure therapy
i'm gonna gently expose somebody to
something until their body stops
reacting to it
and we think we we think it's in our
head like i'm thinking like i just want
to quit having these thoughts dude it's
your body launching into fight-or-flight
as though someone was giving your kid
like arsenic or something
right that's how your body responds well
like
logically i know there's not lead all
over my house but my body's on fire
that's right and here's the thing as
soon as you move from
lead you let lead go your body will move
to something else
right well that's how it was during
pregnancy i was scared of
like toxoplasmosis and all those
terrible things they say will
hurt your baby while they're in the womb
he's born now and i'm like oh i can eat
whatever i want but
now there's other things that's exactly
right um i also by the way i'm not
opposed to a low-dose ssri it to help
rebalance the alarm system so that i can
do the work sometimes the alarms get so
loud it's tough
um
those type of things won't fix the alarm
but it will um
turn the volume down on it so that i can
go face i can walk into the walk into
the into the anxiety sometimes
okay that's something to talk about with
your doctor um don't go into your doctor
and say hey this dude on podcast said i
should be don't do that
you can say hey i'm really um these
these my alarm systems are loud and i
know they're not functioning right
because i know there's no fire in the
kitchen here but they keep going off
um
i want to look at some ways to rebalance
the alarms
my guess is
you've been struggling with this for a
long long long time
and what your body's in desperate need
of and quite frankly you deserve
is 18 months of focused i'm gonna clear
the anxiety from my body
i'm gonna liv i'm gonna intentionally
build a non-anxious life
through relationships through
connection through exercise through
taking care of my thoughts to journaling
to going into the most anxious
situations
to having conversations do you have a
huge family
yeah okay yeah yeah you mentioned that
you have a thousand nieces and nephews
right how many brothers and sisters do
you have
uh five brothers and one sister what
where are you in the hierarchy
uh i'm number seven and i'm
significantly younger than the six okay
so they were all born within ten years
of each other and i was born seven years
after the youngest
okay
so
you can have very loving wonderful
engaged parents
but you had a very different childhood
than your brothers and sisters right
yeah i was raised with 40 year old
parents and they were raised with 20
year old parents
yeah
different people very different people
so you are gonna have to learn a new way
to operate in the world
and i wanna i wanna do a couple things
for you number one i wanna tell you this
directly like i'm looking straight into
the camera right now
i
i've been i haven't been postpartum okay
but i have
the the feelings you're describing i've
felt them i've lived it and it's it's
been tough it's doubled me over okay
yeah and i also want you to know
that putting the work in is worth it
because on the back end i literally
don't have it at all anymore it's gone
it's literally gone
um
and it i feel like my body is completely
rebalanced itself
okay
so i'm telling you that because there's
a light at the end of the tunnel if you
want to do it but it is going to be an
overhaul i had to change the way i do my
life okay
um do you have somebody that you can
tell what's going on in your head too
honestly
oh yeah you do
yeah i i do when i say it i talk i guess
what how do i describe it i say things
very matter effectively and so i've only
ever like actually broken down and cried
once to somebody why is why is there a
gap
i think because i don't want people to
like
actually think that i think that he's
going to get hurt or lead poisoning or
whatever that's not it that's not right
i want them to know
okay that's not it
somewhere along the way you were told
that what you feel and your needs are
not important other people's needs were
more important
yeah and you've been a peacekeeper is
that true
um in some ways i guess
at some point your body will figure out
a way to let
the fears and concerns
out and they will come out in weird
crazy ways if they're compressed
like lead poisoning
mine was i thought they were going to
nationalize housing
i thought that i thought the housing
market would implode again and then the
government's gonna have to come in and
nationalize housing and i was gonna have
to pay like
i and dude i had the math charts that i
drew i mean it was madness
and no amount of wisdom
could talk me out of it
and then i realized well when i was
reading your book and you were talking
about the cracks i'm like that's how i
feel yes yes and yes and yes
usually when somebody's struggling with
ocd and anxiety like like you're
describing again it could be very much
hormonal but you've been dealing with
this for a long time it's often a highly
highly isolated person surrounded by
people who love them
yeah
i am a lighthouse surrounded by sons and
nobody can see me or hear me because
that's my job in this community in this
environment in this family system
and so
i yell inside
and eventually that yelling comes out in
wacko ways
and then there's an industry that tells
me how to solve the wacko ways but never
gets to the core point
and if you are responsible for keeping
mom from from going off or for bothering
dad
or if you are always trying to well your
brother and your sister or sometimes the
youngest kid in your family system
mom and dad are tired
and it's like ah she's just a kid and
you kind of get left to your own devices
and it's cool and it's also whoa
probably not super cool or you make
different decisions or you find yourself
in different situations
or you marry somebody who is so great
but
my job is to make sure he's okay you see
what i'm saying and it just settles in
and often that controls a kid is really
like a simple statement do you see me
and do you still love me
and i i can figure out ways that you can
see me
i'll be seen
right
right
your daughter's your son's lucky to have
you
thank you i talk with a lot of folks who
don't give two craps about their kids
and your son's really really lucky to
have you as his mom
you don't believe that but i i don't lie
on the show
okay you think he got a second rate
broke down mom
who's anxious all the time and you're
not
okay
yeah cool
yeah
um you've got my
which books do you have
um both both okay
um i'm gonna send you something else
that's gonna sound sideways
i'm gonna send you the questions for
humans couples editions both of them
okay i'm also gonna send you the friends
ones and here's why
i want you you still married
yeah
um good guy
yes
are you sure
uh yeah okay yeah cool um
i want you to have some intentional once
a week take these cards out and ask four
or five questions
my guess is you're
you've never fully connected with
somebody there's a disconnect between
your feelings and the words that come
out of your mouth
and that's anxiety
do you ever feel like if you start
crying you'll just never be able to stop
um
sometimes i guess
i cry a lot so it's
it's not something that i like really
prevent myself from doing but you don't
do it with other people
no yeah
well it depends certain people
okay
all right
are you meeting with a counselor
yes okay good
not is it not helping
uh i've i've been bouncing between
counselors
why
well i was seeing one that i really
loved and she did uh eft
and she's just she had a somewhat
inconsistent schedule like i couldn't
see her once a week
and
you just had to get on at the beginning
of the month and schedule all the
appointments that you needed and
sometimes there was only one available
yeah that's true that's not good yeah
that's not great yeah so then so then
you had to play the insurance dance of
who's in network and
anyway so i'm seeing somebody
um not great if they're hey if you've
been through it four times and it's not
good go to somebody else
it's it's talk therapy
okay and i just feel like i want
something more yeah
okay did you get the behavioral things
i'll talk to him real quick one more
time i want you to lean into when you
feel the discomfort your first thought
should not be is this ocd or anxiety or
my mother's intuition
it your first thought should be a smile
on your face even when it's annoying
my body's trying to take care of me
what's my body trying to protect me from
oh my body's trying to protect me from
killing my kid
awesome thank you for that not going to
do that today
i wash my hands and i'm going to feed
the baby and everything my skin is
crawling go wash them again go wash them
again go wash them again
ah thank you
writing down i'm going to keep a little
journal next to me i'm going to write
down wash my hands once before i fed my
kid my body wants me to do it again and
i'm gonna wait nine minutes
i'm gonna wait eight minutes i'm gonna
set a watch
and then i'm gonna practice being
uncomfortable i'm gonna lean directly
into this thing
and then after i feed my kid i'm gonna
watch real close for signs of lead
poisoning which isn't even how that
works but
uh all right and then i'll exhale and if
i got to go wash my hands after 9
minutes 10 minutes after the alarm rings
cool i'll go do that
and i'm going to move it to 11 minutes
i'm going to move it to 15 minutes
and when i'm driving and i start to feel
myself grab the wheel i'm going to let
it go and when i start to say something
to my husband that i need
and i stop myself from it because i
don't want to cause a problem i don't
want to
i don't want to be that guy i'm
i want to be this kind of what
now i'm going to say it
i'm going to say it okay you see what
i'm doing we're practicing discomfort
we're leaning into this stuff okay
yeah
and my promise to you is if you will
take this walk and by the way get some
sleep and by the way
make sure you're taking care of yourself
with exercise make sure you're taking
care of yourself eating make sure you
got a group of women that you do life
with you'll hang out once a week even if
you have to get a babysitter that you
can't afford figure it out
um get with your husband have him keep
your kid get with a neighbor
whatever that looks like
the anxiety alarms will begin to
because your body will realize oh she's
driving she's in control of this thing
for the first time in our life awesome
it's great it's good
it's good
thank you so much for calling emily
you're not broken you're a good mom
and your little boy's lucky to have you
let's all for freedom which means let's
solve for
whoo peace
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless homebuyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades and their home buyer edge
program will help you skip a bunch of
the stress here's how it works apply to
become a churchill certified home buyer
and cap your interest rate for 90 days
then you'll get a 5 000 seller guarantee
to help your offer stand out so go ahead
take a deep breath because churchill has
your back
check them out at churchillmortgage.com
delony and get the homebuyer edge today
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumer access dot org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to andy
in harrisburg what's up andy
hey dr john how are you i'm good what
are you doing
oh right now i'm just actually sitting
on the beach
in my car so that we're not disrupted by
the ocean sounds but uh yeah enjoying a
family vacation well thanks for taking
time away from from the water
for this knuckleheaded podcast that's
fantastic
of course all right let's let's uh let's
solve world hunger what's up
it's not quite as deep as that but i
appreciate you taking time to
navigate this with me
um so i'll try to condense this
basically
what's going on is my future
sister-in-law feels rejected after we
asked her and my brother-in-law not to
bring their dog to our one-year-old's
birthday party
it sounds simple but unfortunately it's
kind of blown up in our face no it's not
simple at all because you're dealing
with madness
yeah it's not simple at all
yeah wow
they chose not to come to the party
um
which initially was kind of like
offensive to us because we were like no
we just want you to be there like we
just don't want your dog there and we
want you guys to come and so it felt to
us like they were kind of like choosing
their dog over our daughter hey hold on
hold on hold on they 100 dead
yeah it's not a feeling it's a it's a
it's a it's it's data it's true
they chose their dog over you
or they chose the principle of nobody's
gonna tell me what to do over
your boundaries
right i think
it stands a little deeper than that for
them though i think that like this
response like was triggered by something
probably in my sister-in-law's past i i
don't know for sure but she doesn't like
does it matter doesn't matter
don't don't get in her head and try to
figure out why she's doing what she's
doing and where it's coming from and all
that doesn't matter yeah
you're gonna make yourself crazy doing
that
and you and your husband are to get into
fights over that
you're going to end up crawling you ever
seen the movie being john malkovich
no i haven't okay it's about they they
find a secret portal behind uh
a file cabinet in an office that gets
them inside of john malkovich's head
it's a bananas movie it's one of the
most incredible movies you can ever see
in your life it's awesome but
it's madness everybody goes crazy
and don't get in her head doesn't matter
yeah she chose her dog over over your
kid
yeah full stop so what happened
so i guess basically we're at the point
where we're hearing from other family
members um two months down the road
where we thought this was you know kind
of all in the past we're hearing from
family members that they're feeling
rejected still and now they're choosing
not to attend family matters that we're
at
and i
in no way thought that this would become
this big of a thing and i i don't want
it is that because you're a rational
human being
well
maybe yes i actually don't want them to
feel hurt and i you can't control
madness you cannot control madness
i know you can't i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry you can't control madness
i just hate that it's affecting like the
rest of the family at this point yes
that's fine we
love them and we love our family and we
want them to be there and feel welcomed
by us and by everyone because they are
but now they're choosing to avoid us
instead of just talking to us about
what's hurting them
and hearing from other people that
they're hurting it's hurtful to us
because
we feel like just talk to us like we're
all adults like we just want to hear
what's up and have you ever
called them
so we actually didn't call them but we
met we tried to meet up with them for
brunch we're actually about two hours
apart they're in a different city and
they don't own a car
um so it was really more on us to like
why don't they own a car
um they live in philadelphia so they
just don't really need one um they walk
and you know take public transit so
um yeah i think basically we had you
know basically planned to have brunch
with them just spur of the moment since
we were going to be in the city and
my sister my future sister-in-law chose
not to show up and initially i thought
what was just last minute she probably
just like had other plans but then
my brother-in-law told us that like she
just chose not to come and that she was
sleeping in and like we had our daughter
with us thinking like okay like they'll
want to see her like even if they don't
want to see us shortly they'll want to
see her after not being able to be at
her party um but yeah apparently there
was still hurt stemming from that
um okay so
let me be
super direct is that cool
yeah this has very little if not nothing
to do with the dog
right
yeah we've realized that this is a woman
who does not like you and does not like
your husband or does not like your unit
or doesn't like anybody taking attention
from her precious little fiancee
and wants her world exactly how she
wants her world and has a picture of it
and will not deviate from it in fact
we'll act like a child a
a elementary school child not even a
middle schooler i've got one of those
this is an elementary school move
um and
there is literally nothing you can do
about it except treat her with dignity
respect and go on with your day
you'll have to grieve this like crazy
because you probably had a dream that
you and your brother's wife would become
best buds and she'd be the greatest aunt
ever
and you maybe even met her at a family
party once or twice and thought she's
hilarious and fun or weird and eccentric
or whatever
and you created a picture of what life
was gonna be and that picture's not
gonna come true
and you're gonna just have to grieve it
and i would be really direct with my
other family members
i am sorry they chose
their dog over our kid
and if they choose to not want to be
around us because we have boundaries
then that's the choice they make and
unfortunately if they choose if your
rest of your family chooses that
golly that's going to feel like you're
on an island but your boundaries are
still your boundaries and if you start
now trying to chase making other people
happy like that in your family
man that's a recipe for disaster
yeah you know what i mean
i hate this for you
i wish i could just be we could all
laugh and be like i just call her and
tell her whatever
yeah
so i mean i guess like my husband and i
are at the point where
we feel like
it's worth trying to mend at least
attempting like we would really like to
still have a relationship with them even
if it is just the three times a year we
see them
they don't want a relationship with you
but i think they do they are hurt by
this like
they don't
have they have they called you and said
we're hurt by this
no
have they written you a letter just said
hey we were caught off guard we don't
have kids this our little dog is our
only kid and it it sounds lame but it
means something to us
and
it just bummed us out that you put that
did they do that
no i wish they would have no they talk
crap about you to other people they're
trying to rally troops to their side
they don't even show up when you drive
two hours to be on their town with your
new baby
they don't show up
they don't want to be in a relationship
with you
and i hate to be the guy that's telling
you that
you want them to want to
but they don't what they want is their
world on their terms and they can have
it
but you've chosen to not meet some of
those terms and so they took their ball
and went home
yeah
and i hate that
yeah because it's so immature and it's
so lame
and i want you to hear notice something
i've never asked you one time why you
did not want that dog in your house you
know why doesn't matter
does not matter
you ask for them to not bring their dog
who cares why
you know what i mean
silly to like ask them not to bring
their dog and unfortunately we did
communicate it like only
it was a little less than a week ahead
of time so we had told them about the
party months in advance and then
found out they were gonna bring their
dog and ask them not to um and so that's
like obviously where all this stems from
but i some of me feels like this is
deeper obviously steeper than that but
somebody feels like there has to be
something else that they're frustrated
with us about for this to become this
big
but i don't i like i'm just thinking
like what could that be and like what
it's very common for little things like
your brother is talking about well my
sister when they got married fill in the
blank or my sister is awesome
she does this and they have kids and my
brother-in-law is doing this
and unfortunately it's common
that
a
new person marrying into a family feels
threatened by that relationship between
a brother and a sister
feels threatened by that relationship
between the brother and other members of
their family
and so they don't blow it up they do
sometimes but that's easy to spot right
that's simple
they don't blow it up from the
one-up position right you can't go see
her i don't like they don't do that
they just
they they blow it up from they drown it
from the one down position they just
grab the rope of the boat and slowly
pull it
i'm just not gonna go
i just don't feel like it i'm
uncomfortable i'm tired it's not gonna
go
and then eventually your brother will
get tired showing up to things by
himself and he'll just stay home too
right yeah so it's actually my husband's
brother but yeah i mean we're still yeah
i guess like i understand what you're
saying how like it seems like they don't
want to be in our lives but at the same
time we'd like to at least try to amend
it even though
they haven't really put foot forth
effort to we'd really like to try and i
feel like
personally kind of feel like we owe it
to my mother and father-in-law to try
because they're the ones that like told
us kind of how this was all playing out
so now you're responsible for how your
in-laws feel
because they don't have the courage to
tell their kids
y'all are being ridiculous
put the dog in a dumb kennel and go see
your your niece
yeah i mean i kind of wish that was
their response but it worked you can't
manage this and i hate that now listen
i'm with you
hear me say this
pretend you're the guy calling me and
say hey i dated this girl for a while
and then all of a sudden she quit
talking to me
and um
i reached out and we were gonna get
together for coffee and then she just
said i'm sleeping in
and
um i had something really important to
to show her and she's like i just blew
me off
i think she really still loves me
um
but i i'm gonna try one more overture
i would say this she doesn't but go for
it anyway okay so if i'm you i would do
some i would make sure i'd crossed all
the t's and dot all the eyes
yeah
just because you told them a week ahead
of time
doesn't mean you're at fault because you
didn't know about the dog until a week
ahead of time because if somebody's
gonna bring a pet to somebody's a
stranger's house usually they they let
you know
my parents do that every year they have
a little wiener dog
named rachel
and
they call and say hey is it cool for
bringing the dog sometimes it is last
year we were like hey can you just board
that dog
and they were like yeah no problem and
they boarded the dog for a week and you
know what this is crazy hold your breath
everybody the dog was just fine
just fine just fine yeah
um but yeah sometimes she brings it
sometimes sometimes i bring it sometimes
they don't but it's something they
always mention because my parents are
grown-ups
young adults right so you found out
about it late
and then
you're not the bad guy when you said
well that we just found out about this
not cool
right
yeah and i think part of the reason they
felt they could just bring their dog
without asking is because the party was
being
held at my in-laws and they have like an
open door policy to pet
but it was us hosting the party and like
we invited them and we didn't realize
that
it doesn't matter
i know i guess i'm just trying to defend
their side of things but i'm you know i
really don't feel like
all of it's about the dog it's just it
sucks that it's come to this little
thing yes it's not about the dog it's
not about the dog
if it was about the dog this would have
been long gone and over
yeah
long gone and over it's stupid you can't
it's it's it it would have been
so dumb i can't bring my dog you're a
crazy overprotective new mother
and you would have been like well it's
crazy that you can't not have your dog
for a few hours on a saturday and then
y'all have been like i know i know all
right i'll get let's go get beers and it
would have been over right
that little dialogue and then we all get
over it and so like have the party have
fun yes or even just like them telling
us that like hey they're major offended
and maybe we can reevaluate and figure
out a way to get their dog there and
keep it inside but that wasn't
communicated so now it's like a big
thing right here's the true conversation
your husband needs to have this with his
brother
brother to brother man to man
and i don't mean like some like duel
but
like he needs to call his brother and
say we're you and i are meeting
this isn't a question this is a
statement we're meeting i'll drive down
to philly to talk to you we need to have
this hard conversation what is happening
i'm not interested in going through my
life without my brother in it and my
wife is an integral part of my life your
fiance is about to be a part of your
life which means they're all part of all
of our lives what in the world
that's what needs to happen
yeah and do you think it would be
appropriate to have that conversation
like the four of us versus not them not
yet they need to have it themselves
okay these are two brothers man acting
like
this whole conversation i i thought you
were talking about it was you and him
you and your brother
yeah man these are two brothers and you
don't have a conversation and mom and
dad quite frankly need to butt out of it
yeah
they just need to get over it
yeah i really do feel like the issue is
unfortunately more
my future sister-in-law somehow having
an issue with me so that's why i was
wondering if
probably should do it the four of us
like not yet at some point yes if if
there's healing to take place and people
are going to act like grown-ups then yes
it'll probably include you and her
getting in a room and saying i like you
i don't know where we got sideways but
what can we do to move forward right
yeah and um i think the conversation
starts with your brother because here's
what's gonna happen you're gonna find
out that you said something seven months
ago that you have no recollection of
that hit her in the wrong way on the
wrong day for the wrong reason and it
started a one degree turn sideways
and now it's
it's a mess or she just doesn't like you
and doesn't want to be a part of this
big family and blah blah blah blah blah
at the end of the day doesn't matter
because you can't get in her head
yeah
but here's what
like before we get off the phone hear me
say this
you are responsible for your boundaries
and you are responsible for treating
people with dignity and respect and
kindness
right yeah you cannot control how they
respond and choose to act
and guilt guilt is fine guilt's just a
signal right it's just a it's a feeling
it's good it's important
but it's something you look at because
our feelings don't always tell us the
truth
and i can feel guilty about something i
feel sad for the way somebody feels i
feel bummed out that my in-laws
are mad at me i feel bummed out that my
brother-in-law's fiance is
a middle schooler or not even a middle
school or an elementary school kid
um
and then suddenly you deconstruct that
guilt and it's not really guilt at all
it's just sad i'm sad i had a picture
it's grief i i wanted it to be like this
and it actually is like this
yeah and it's a bummer but dude i i
think your brother should call his
brother today
and say just cut through the nonsense
you and i are meeting we gotta figure
this out
i have a feeling my husband's not to
like that response why why would he not
do that why do i call his brother
i feel like at this point we're just
both like we just want it to be resolved
and like he kind of feels like it's
well i don't know if he feels this way
but i feel like it is more from like my
sister-in-law's future sister-in-law's
side but he doesn't have any business
talking to your brother his brother's
girlfriend
call his brother and say what in the
world because at least his brother's
gonna have a true honest
discussion
and if he's already choosing
um if if younger brother is already
choosing fiance over a conversation with
his brother
you you then you have a big neon sign to
where the problem is
yeah
and i i just breaks my heart
breaks my heart but at least when mom
and dad call back
he can say hey i called brother he wants
nothing to do with me
he doesn't want to have a conversation
with me he's still acting like a middle
school kid blah blah blah sorry i did i
reached out to him i went and visited
him he didn't show up she didn't show up
he won't have an honest truthful
conversation at least you can report
that back up to mother and dad so that
they can call him and say what's the
matter with you i raised you better than
this
but here so everybody listening real
quick
people in your life
are going to come up with new boundaries
they're going to say no
they're going to say no thank you or i'm
not
that's not
this thing isn't welcome here whether
it's a dog or a pet or your loud
f550 with the with the glass packs on it
or whatever you're doing
fine
cool somebody's put a boundary in and
you don't like that boundary
you choose well then if my f550 can't
show up if i can't show up to your kid's
birthday party with my ar strapped on my
back whatever the thing is if i can't do
it
um i'm opting out great opt out but do
it with class and dignity and just say
hey thanks uh we're not gonna make it um
or i'm gonna choose to
um
i travel only with my dog it's helpful
for me and i understand you want my dog
there so that's great so we're going to
pass on the birthday party but we'll
catch up at another time
just being adult about it just be grown
up about it
and if you're marrying into a family
you're marrying everybody in that family
make peace with it and if you marry
somebody who has a great relationship
with their sibling don't blow that up
honor that love it be so excited about
it
do whatever you can to to nourish that
relationship
[Music]
conflict deferred is conflict amplified
have the conversation we'll be right
back
hey what's up delona here i've got a
word from our sponsor betterhelp i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done
it's that deep feeling of exhaustion
after a long period of being overworked
and overstressed and just fried and most
of us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
delony that's betterhelphelp.com
all right i just want to sit here and
sing who let the dogs out
who
who but i won't we'll take uh one more
call let's go to sylvia in the city of
angels los angeles what's up sylvia
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm doing well thank yeah you just hit
me with that conflict deferred conflict
amplified uh-oh
oh oh i feel like
that's what we're gonna end my call too
oh great all right so what's up
so my direct question is
should i reach out to my son's father
who i haven't talked to since my son was
basically born
tell me more
so i'm really nervous
okay
so
we dated for about six months
um
and in those six months
the last time i saw him we were intimate
and we used the plan b
and
after that like we that was the last
time i saw him we were on the we kept
talking but i realized like
maybe i don't want to be with him
and i didn't know i was pregnant and
then i was okay so y'all y'all hooked up
y'all slept together you went the next
day
took the plan b pill and then moved on
with your day and then a couple of days
a couple weeks later y'all broke up and
you moved on with your life
yeah and then six weeks later i found
out i was pregnant okay
so when i told him about it we were
already broken up
and
he told me to
terminate the pregnancy okay and i said
i wasn't gonna do that and and
he just kept pressuring me and
pressuring me to have
an abortion and i just kept saying no
so
for the first six months of my pregnancy
um i i tried to not answer his message i
didn't see him at all through my whole
pregnancy well during the six first six
months we almost didn't talk but when i
was six months he came back and was
supposedly okay let's let's try to work
things out but we never actually saw
each other
and then like a month later
you know when i was seven months
pregnant he's like you know what never
mind i'm not ready to be a father and i
don't understand why you decided to keep
this child you're putting me in a bad
situation you've ruined my life
you just got pregnant for a paycheck
and he just
i mean i don't want to cry but he just
like i just felt really humiliated
what he said to you it's cowardly and
it's disgusting and it's childish
i'm sorry that somebody did that to you
yeah so
we i kept communication open for my son
because i felt like
you know maybe eventually he'll change
his mind and this is his first child
maybe he'll want to come around
so
i said
if you don't talk to me respectfully i'm
not going to respond
but if you want to know how the
pregnancy is going how
the baby is
uh will respond to those questions so we
did continue communication in that way
and when i went into labor we were we
were talking and hold on you keep
talking about communication and
y'all were talking
are you just talking about y'all are
texting each other
yes because i was like listen listen to
him that is not communication
you are passing data back and forth to
each other
you have not had a real relationship
with him no that's
if you're afraid that's wise if you're
afraid wise good move on your part
but it really sounds like
you had a picture in your head
that you weren't going to be one of
those people who had a kid by themself
like that's not going to happen to me
and it happened to you
exactly you've been propping up this
picture
for a long time now
and
it the guy left
he told you he wanted you to kill the
baby and move on with your life
yes
so he's told you what he wants
what's
absolutely melting you from the inside
out is the energy you're spending trying
to prop up a picture of something that's
gone
do you see what i'm saying
yeah
in a strange way the conflict deferred
statement is you you're at conflict with
you
this guy's told you he left you
he left his beautiful son
he left
god it's making me so just
unbelievable
i'm heartbroken for you like in a deep
way because i don't like to be out of
town more than a day away from my kids i
can't wrap my head around somebody who
would want to walk away from their kids
i can't i don't have the psychology for
it i can't wrap my head around it's not
something i can understand
i know i'm
my son is three years old and i've only
left them with us with my sister to
watch three times in here in his whole
life well that's gonna make you crazy
sylvia
you need to go do fun things too you
need to have friends you need to be out
having fun and he can stay with a
babysitter or a family member you know
what i mean
yeah so why why is this just now coming
back up why are you just now wondering
should i reach out
because my son is talking now
and he's very smart and he notices like
cartoons have like songs have mom and
dad
you know coco melon is
daddy and mommy and
you know baby shark is mama shark papa
shark everything like bluey has this
papa bluey hey blues bluey's dad is
screwing it up for everybody that guy's
like dad of the century
i watched that show and i'm like man
level up delony like yes so blue is not
really fair that that's incredible
yeah so i know i just kind of feel like
it's gonna come it is it is mine it is
and here's the response
daddy wasn't well and so he uh chose to
go
daddy loves you and um but daddy was not
well that he was sick
and he chose to go away
and here's the unfortunate thing
you know this as well as i do
that little boy's going to wonder what
he did wrong
to send that away
he's going to wonder that for the rest
of his life
and here's what's going to happen you're
going to do a really great job raising
this little boy
he won the lottery with you as a mama
and you're going to do a great job
and then at some point dad's going to
swoop back in
and everything in your life is
going to be gritting your teeth and say
stay away from that man he's a bad man
and at some point you're gonna have to
choose peace and you're gonna have to
choose forgiveness because that's the
father of your son and if you talk bad
about him or if he comes to believe that
dad is evil and wrong that little boy
knows that half of me is him so your
son's going to walk around feeling like
half of him is broken and def and
defective
i'm not planning on on that um i never
talked bad about him no i know i know i
know i know i'm just saying like it like
it's gonna be a tough road to hoe that's
what happens when dads walk out on their
families
yeah i mean honestly i wish it would
happen sooner rather than later for my
son's sake
and like you're saying i will always try
to keep peace but at the same time i'm
afraid that when he does come every
little
situation would be like well i told you
not to have him
or you know
you're making yourself crazy trying to
prop up a picture that's not gonna
happen
the guy's gone when's the last time you
had a face-to-face conversation with him
when we conceived a baby
four and a half years ago
when's the last time you had a text
message conversation with him
when my son was five days old so it's
been three years
yeah do you even know where he is
no
last time we spoke he said he had bought
a house in another state but i don't
know if he's still there
um
i'll give you
my thoughts
i think you should take him to court for
child support
and
i think he should be
um
take care of if he wants to walk away
and
and neglect his family in that way
whatever um but he's got a financial
responsibility to this kid
that's what i think
um and it and
or you can just wipe your hands of it
and be done
and as he gets older
he's gonna have to reckon with it wasn't
me there was something wrong with my dad
that made him do a very unnatural act
which was to leave
a pregnant mom
and then he's gonna have to make peace
with that inside of him
and that's gonna be his healing
adventure that he goes on probably for a
long long time
yeah a lot of
well my my family totally does not want
me to put him on child support but i
have a
couple
because
truthfully i don't need him financially
i mean extra
money will always help i can put it in
my son's savings account or something
but truthfully i don't need his money
okay um and i just feel like i don't
know i don't know how much he would give
me like 300 500 whatever amount it is
it's not worth for me him telling me
see
i told you you just did this for a
paycheck and you just did this
you know he threw a grenade at you
when he was a scared kid
he threw a grenade at you that is still
burning through your heart
he said some stupid stuff
that doesn't neglect the fact
that he needs to take financial
responsibility for his son
right and you're you you are you are
suffering
because you don't want to fulfill an
insult that he made to you
yeah
banana sylvia
he doesn't get a vote man
he doesn't get a vote
and how you feel he cashed that out
he doesn't get a vote how you feel he
doesn't get a vote how he raises how
this kid gets raised he doesn't get a
vote he left he walked away do you still
have all those text messages
again yeah
yeah i would save all those i'd print
them off somehow
yeah i do they're gonna look great being
read in court
telling me that i ruined his life
that
that he told me um
he told me that every time he because i
wanted him to be more sylvia why are you
giving him voice into your head this
many years later
maybe because i don't know at this point
without i grew up without my dad i know
i want to do everything possible for my
son to have a father he left you he left
he left
yeah
and that's because something was
something was wrong with him not you
and you still carry it around that your
dad left because of something you did
that's not true
your dad left because of him not you
quit carrying that around sylvia
actually i i was in therapy and my
therapist said you know because i told
her
when do you think i'll have a
breakthrough you know and she said when
you don't
hold regret or not regret when you don't
hold like
uh grudge or hate towards your dad
and
and when she said that i'm like never
like that's never gonna happen but now i
realize now i i
i do feel that way i'm like it wasn't me
he had his own priorities and obviously
i wasn't working no no no no no no no
okay here's what you got to do
you've got uh here's your homework
assignment you ready
i want you to pick up
um i want you to go to home depot and
it'll cost you like five bucks
okay
that's like one
one
twentieth or one one hundredth of a of a
price of a psychiatrist visit okay
i want you to pick up um go to the back
of the garden section and pick up a
landscaping brick
and i want you to put a piece of duct
tape over that brick and i want you to
write
dad left
and i'm mad
and i want you to carry that brick
around for an hour around your house you
cannot set it down you can't put it on
your lap you have to hold it
okay and i want you just to keep
carrying it when you go to the grocery
store when you go in the backyard and
you take the trash out whatever it is
you're doing you play with your son he's
like mommy why are you carrying that
particular bag because some [ __ ] on a
podcast told me to do it
and i want you to carry it around and
your shoulders are going to ache and
your hands are going to get tired
and at some point i want you to take
that brick out in your backyard and
throw it as far as you can and never
pick it up again
that is forgiveness
forgiveness doesn't let your dad off the
hook forgiveness says i'm not carrying
your poison anymore
because right now sylvia you are
drinking poison every day of your life
hoping your dad feels it and he doesn't
yeah and you're like my son's death yes
and you're picking up a cup of poison
from your son's dad and you drink it
every morning hoping that he feels it
and he doesn't
the only person who's getting poisoned
is you
stop
you're worth so much more than this
right
yeah yes
let it let set it down
set it down you are gonna have to be
highly intentional about putting other
men in your son's life he's gonna need
men
not saying like have a rotation of of
people you're dating through the house
he's gonna need a grandparent or uncles
or
men that you trust from a local church
or from a local school that will lean
into his life and so you're gonna be
proactive
hey you're a man in my life that i trust
would you be willing to take my son for
an hour a week and just go play
just let him have some interaction time
go kick a soccer ball go throw a ball go
rough house go do something take him to
a park
and there are men who will do that i've
done that for people
there are men who will step up and do
that because there's some extraordinary
men out there
but at this point it's been four and a
half years you're hanging on to a ghost
you're hanging on to a wisp to an ether
that doesn't exist the man left
he said i want you to kill this baby
because you've ruined my life i'm gone
and he left he's gone
and you say you don't you don't need his
financial support and it's not even
worth the drama oh that's your life i'll
support you on that
[Music]
stop drinking poison sylvia stop
you're worth a good night's sleep
you're worth laughter you're worth
loving again
all these things you didn't screw up you
didn't do anything wrong
you're a good mom
carry that brick around for a while and
then i want you to feel what it feels
like to set it down
and i'll say it one more time
your dad left because there was
something wrong with him
not you
the father of your son left because he
was struggling with whatever he's
struggling with
not because of you
stop carrying that set it down
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right in honor of that second call
today
song of the day is the classic
um y'all absolutely don't know this but
whenever kelly wears something low-cut
in the back across the top of her
shoulders in old english she has
tattooed baja men
she loves them
um the baja men classic who let the dogs
out and it goes like this who let the
dogs out
well done
well the party was nice i'm not even
gonna do it who let the dogs out way to
go america we'll see you soon
[Music]
you